[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité est une femme en perpétuel
mouvement perpétuel mutation ne la
mettez surtout pas dans une case elle
est addition additionné au sens de
Romain gar l'un de ses mentors tantôt
sportif de haut niveau tantôt actrice
tantôt conseillère politique tantôt
rppeuse toute sa vie elle a sauté d'un
univers à l'autre d'un monde à l'autre
peut-être pour échapper aux assignations
peut-être porté aussi par une immense
curiosité par un besoin vicéral de
rassembler d'unir de mettre en relation
universel universalité universalisme
tels sont ses maîtres mots à un moment
où l'époque a plutôt tendance à menter à
séparer à communautariser elle cherche
au contraire par sa propre histoire par
ses actions et par ses mots à créer des
chemins communs des points de
convergence alors cela fait débat cela
fait même polémique elle est parfois au
cœur de clash sur Twitter par exemple
qu'elle utilise justement pour pointer
l'ennemi un peu comme une gladiatrice
qui se lancerait dans l'arène y a-t-il
d'ailleurs un peu de sacrifice derrière
tout cela y va-t-elle parce que c'est
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux que
le combat des idées se mène posonsl
toutes ces questions bienvenue dans un
monde un regard bienvenue Rachel CAN et
merci d'être ici avec nous et merci à
vous au Sénat dans ce dô tournant ce
lieu si particulier les réseaux sociaux
disons-le sont comme une une fausse au
lion vous n'hésitez pas à vous y jeter
est-ce qu'il y a comme une mission
est-ce qu'il y a comme du sacrifice
derrière tout cela je crois je crois
mais dans notre période actuelle où où
l'expression est multiple dans les
médias les journaux mais aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux je S bien qu'il y a une
volonté de faire taire l'humanisme de
faire taire l'universalisme et c'est
pour ça que je m'y exprime en fait voilà
est-ce que c'est pas illusoire est-ce
que vous dites pas vous-même parfois que
c'est un peu peine perdu que c'est
impossible de convaincre sur Twitter que
c'est un lieu de de combat plus que de
débat c'est un lieu de combat je ne
perds jamais espoir ça c'est
vrai c'est un état d'esprit hein je suis
en vie donc je ne perds pas espoir c'est
un lieu de de combat peut-être j'ai pas
envie de forcément de convaincre mais en
tout cas de pointer du doigt ce qui
n'est plus en rapport avec nos humanités
de pointer du doigt les incohérences de
pointer du doigt la haine de pointer du
doigt ce qui ne fait pas avancer notre
France celle que je chéris sous votre
photo de profil il y a l'hyne à la joie
c'est c'est en un pied de nez à tous
ceux qui justement prendrai autre chose
que la paix et la joie exactement c'est
un pied de né à ceux qui prônent la
haine aux influenceurs de haine les
communautarismes les intolérances tous
ceux qui nous fracturent qui veulent
nous diviser et puis j'ai pris cette
musique parce que la musique c'est le
c'est le plus court chemin d'un cœur à
l'autre et évidemment avec cette
Europe pleine d'espoir cette Europe en
construction j'avais envie de reparler
avec un autre langage qui est le langage
mus
parce que pour moi les artistes sont les
législateurs de l'ombre il ne faut
jamais oublier cela oui parce que
l'hymne à la joie c'est l'hyne européen
je le précise pour nos téléspectateurs
parmi ceux qui vous ciblent et que vous
ciblez il y a les défenseurs de ce qu'on
appelle le décolonialisme pour faire
simple si je résume ce sont ceux qui voi
en l'homme blanc l'éternel colon
persécuteur et qui veulent qu'on laisse
désormais la place aux persécutés aux
descendant d'immigrer à ce qu'on appelle
les ce que certains appellent les
racisés les victimes de
racisme vous vous la détesté cette
position victimaire ça fait partie de
vos combats ça fait partie d'un d'un oui
c'est
un un de mes plus grands combats en fait
parce que la
victimocratie c'était partie de la
victimisation au début mais maintenant
on entend bien que c'est de la
victimocratie c'est-à-dire qu'on est à
l'encontre de ce qui s'est passé pour la
Révolution française c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait on prend soit votre genre soit
votre race soit votre religion pour en
faire finalement un trophée un espèce de
bouclier une forme d'immunité où
finalement si on est noir arabe musulman
si on est femme on pourrait dire tout et
n'importe quoi et on pourrait s'attaquer
à l'État de droit et ça en fait c'est
aux antipodes de la Révolution française
c'est aux antipodes de l'État de droit
c'est aux antipode de la démocratie on a
quand même une un principe qui est le
plus précieux dans notre République
c'est h nous somes tous égau devant la
loi h et donc on doit tous respecter la
loi et nous ne sommes pas un peuple
religieux nous ne sommes pas un peuple
ethnique nous ne sommes pas un peuple
racial nous sommes un peuple politique
qui nous nous retrouvons autour de nos
fondamentaux communs liberté égalité
fraternité cette victimocratie elle nous
tue mais comment expliquez-vous qu'elle
prennent cette idéologie au départ elle
vient d'Amérique du Sud elle s'est
étendu à l'Amérique du Nord aujourd'hui
elle est en Europe aussi en France
peut-être que la France résiste Davant
que les autres pays vous allez peut-être
me le dire en tout cas ça prend comment
expliquez-vous que c laa prenne ça parle
aux gens oui mais c'est multi factoriel
ouais la première chose c'est qu'il y a
une véritable colonisation idéologique
alors c'est très paradoxal parce que ce
sont les décoloniaux en fait qui prônent
cette colonisation là et les États-Unis
via le soft power américain donc la
culture on a été on est dans un dans un
berceau enfin on est un Bibé de cette
culture amériain
sur la victimocratie sur la question
raciale on le on le voit avec cette
question de violence policière qui a été
importé des États-Unis et que finalement
ça joue avec les colères et les névroses
sociales pour se dresser contre l'État
ça joue avec la haine de la France et
donc avec ces colères là c'est du
populisme on fait avec cette colère là
pour entraîner notamment les jeunes dans
cette victimisation là on ne vous aime
pas et ce mot racisé il est éperdument
dangereux parce qu'en fait il ne fait
pas avec l'existence il fait avec
l'essence vous êtes racisé depuis la
naissance ça veut dire que la votre
promesse de vie c'est que vous soyez
dans des discrimination de par l'état de
par les l'homme blanc de par la femme
blanche depuis votre naissance donc ça
crée la division depuis votre naissance
et quelle que soit votre vie vous
mourrez rassisé c'est l'inverse de la
méritocrati mais mais ça répond
peut-être à une souffrance que vous avez
peut-être vous-même ressenti parce que
le public l'a peut-être oublié mais vous
avez vous-même à un moment donné pris ce
chemin vous faisiez partie du collectif
qui a écrit noir n'est pas mon métier
vous l'avez probablement ressenti cette
souffrance d'être assigné à quelque
chose parce que noir absolument mais
c'est-à-dire que c'est parce que j'ai un
amour éperdu pour l'égalité j'ai un
amour éperdu pour la justice et pour la
lutte contre toutes les formes de
discrimination l'antisémitisme le le
racisme l'homophobie et j'en passe c'est
parce que j'ai un amour de ça que le
combat n'a plus été possible au sein de
ce collectif noir n'est pas un métier je
ne supporte pas lorsque noir n'est pas
un métier est devenu un métier de haine
contre l'homme blanc et de reproduire un
processus discriminatoire c'est c'est
impossible en fait d'utiliser
l'antiracisme pour être raciste à son
tour raciste les mots intersectionnalité
racisé communauté tout cela vous le
rejetez vous êtes une ardente défenseuse
de ce que j'ai appeler l'universalité
dans mon introduction on peut lire
d'ailleurs dans votre livre racé qui a
été publié aux éditions l'Observatoire
et quelque part est-ce que ce n'est pas
rassurant d'appartenir à une communauté
d'appartenir à un groupe qui a les mêmes
codes que vous dans un monde justement
où l'universalité l'universalisme
pourrait donner le vertige et où
l'universalisme pourrait disons-le aussi
être dominé par une ou deux cultures
notamment américaine vous voyez ce que
je veux dire est-ce que c'est c'est pas
c'est pas ça vient pas d'un besoin aussi
d'être dans un groupe identifié qui Mang
les mêmes plats qui célèbr les mêmes
fêtes et qui fait du bien aussi dans un
monde où tout est trop universel
peut-être j'entends parfaitement mais
alors je suis le le plus mauvais public
pour répondre à cette question j'ai
grandi euh dans cette famille ma maman
est est née en 40 donc ma maman enfant
caché
euh on avait rayé son nom elle s'appelit
Hertz normalement on l'a appelé renard
de 0 à 5 ans elle a retrouvé son nom de
famille après la guerre elle a épousé un
monsieur très noir musulman
animiste et j'ai grandi dans cette
famille là moi donc en fait mes repères
là où je me sens en sécurité c'est dans
l'universalité c'est pas dans une
communauté lorsque je vois que je suis
dans Je seraiis dans un groupe où tout
le monde se ressemble ouis dans un
esphère une espèce de de de clan
clonique h c'est terrorisant cette idée
de race pure cette idée de de gommer
toutes les différences toutes les
signatures toutes les singularités moi
ça me terrorise moi je me sens bien dans
la République où chaque individu est
différent pour créer son propre récit et
c'est la conjugaison de l'ensemble de
nos récits qui fait ce récit national h
donc vous avez du mal à entendre he que
certains disent oui mais moi j'ai aussi
besoin quand je rentre chez moi dans ma
ville dans ma cité dans ma petite
localité dans mon petit village des gens
qui ont mes codes il faut des gens avec
ses propres codes bien sûr que ça
rassure mais ça ça c'est de l'ordre de
l'intimité c'est très intéressant quand
l'intimité se conjugue avec un appel
d'air qui est l'autre moi en tant que
aproidich française et perdument
française mais afrid j'ai toujours été
l'autre de quelqu'un c'est quand je suis
avec les Noirs je suis l'autre quand je
suis dans les communautés juif je suis
l'autre quand je suis avec les musulmans
je suis l'autre je suis toujours l'autre
et je crois que c'est ça la République
fraternité ce principe qu'on oublie
c'est être l'autre c'est voir l'autre
même si on se ressemble on est toujours
l'autre de toute façon vous nous l'avez
un peu dit Rachel Cann cette
universalité elle a bercé votre enfance
vous l'avez vécu dans votre cellule
familiale alors je vais préciser un peu
pour nos téléspectateurs une mère juive
ahquenase de Pologne enfant caché
pendant la Choa un père gambien dont les
langues maternelles étaient le serire le
wallof le peull vous me dites si je me
trompe puis l'anglais langue coloniale
et bien plus tard d'ailleurs le français
il a été prof de français en Gambie puis
prof d'anglais en France il rencontre
votre mère à tour dans sa librairie
votre grand-père maternel lui parlait le
yidich et vous dites quelque chose de
très beau à propos de ces langues qui
ont bercé votre enfance et de ses
accents vous dites ça m'a appris à
savoir écouter l'autre tous les autres
donc oui parce que petite quand on a un
accent wolof ou serer qui fait des
blagues avec un accent yidich je vous
assure que en fait ça vous a apprend des
différentes tonalités et comment à
travers leurs mots il il il il
trouvaient l'harmonie en fait et ça je
trouve que et en français parce qu'en
fait c'est des accents mais dans la
langue française et ça faisait au fond
vivre cette Francophonie dont on parle à
travers le monde mais euh mais à table
donc c'était assez fascinant et c'est
vrai que l'écoute dans ce monde de bruit
il faudrait revaloriser l'écoute
notamment
dès l'école primaire ou dès la dernière
année de maternelle parce qu'on manque
et perdument d'écoute et et et donc
comme on manque d'écoute on démonétise
on dévalorise le dialogue est-ce que
c'est difficile parfois d'être la somme
de toutes ces
identités la somme
l'addition ça a pu l'être notamment
quand j'étais
adolescente parce que c'est vrai
qu'adolescent on a besoin
d'avoir une case pour mieux se définir
et cetera mais en grandissant c'est très
fatiguant mais en
[Musique]
grandissant ça me permet d'embrasser
cette universalité en fait et de la
défendre et de la défendre puissamment
c'estàd que pour moi l'universalisme ce
n'est pas un concept c'est pas de la
philosophie c'est ancré c'est incarné il
y a aussi beaucoup de religions dans
votre famille toutes les religions vous
disiez même votre père animiste vous
vous êtes vous-même croyante vous
pratiquez plusieurs fêtes vous dites que
vous pratiquez les fêtes catholiques les
fêtes juifes parfois les fêtes
musulmanes aussi et vous êtes une
ardente défenseuse de la laïcité
certains pourrait y voir un paradoxe
vous non au contraire ah oui ben non au
contraire ah bah au contraire non non
c'est vrai qu'il y a du catholicisme du
judaïsme euh et c'est vrai vous
pratiquez un peu de toutes ces religions
alors moi lorsque notamment moi c'est
vrai qu'il y a des années lorsque je
suis au
Sénégal et qu'on fait tabaskii donc la
fête du mouton c'est Tabaski c'est la en
fait hein donc Tabaski après quand il y
a des fêtes bah je les suis donc je je
pratique mon islam et notamment avec
avec mes
tantes et puis ici c'est vrai que bah
entre Noël Pâques mais après moi j'ai
reçu l'éducation religieuse juive vous
avez pris des cours de talmut depuis mes
7 ans les cours de talmut Tor et donc
voilà je suis juive mais après dans
cette famille éperdument laïque ça veut
dire où toutes les ig finalement sont
mis en œuvre et surtout avec des parents
alors ma mère n'est je crois qu'elle
n'est pas très croyante mais peut-être
qu'ussi par rapport à son histoire c'est
vrai que mon grand-père est revenu et il
a des camps bien s et il a arrêté
d'aller à la choule mais sy la synagogue
pardon la choule c'est en guidich donc
la synagogue c'est vrai qu'il a arrêté
mais lorsqu'il a su que j'allais au
talmutora je sais que ça lui faisait
éperdument plaisir euh après mon père
est croyant donc lui alors il y a eu
vous savez il était animiste mais il y a
eu il y a eu l'islamisation
euh l'évangélisation puis une forte
islamisation au moment de la de la
décolonisation en réalité donc il
pratique il pratique tout ça c'est c'est
un mélange au Sénégal hein ce qui est
pratiqué mais alors vous dites que vous
en avez presque voulu à vos parents de
vous avoir élevé justement dans cet
universalisme au quotidien parce que
vous avez fait des études notamment un
3ème cycle à Assas un jour vous êtes
rentré d'une journée à la fac en lui
disant papa je crois qu'ils sont
racistes et votre père vous a engueulé
vous avez dit va bosser et c'est marrant
que plutôt que d'y voir une injustice
une source de colère finalement il en a
fait une force et et vous aussi oui
c'estd que c'est vrai que c'est facile
de se victimiser mais je l'ai détesté
mon père c'estd j'ai dit mais quelle
absence d'empathie c'estd que je suis en
train de vivre des trucs qui sont d'une
injustice sans nom donc de vivre
l'injustice dans une faque de droit
c'est commandme une mise en abîme qui
est assez
détestable j'en ai voulu beaucoup à mes
parents parce qu'en fait ils m'ont élevé
dans un monde de bismounours où au fond
oui les Juifs sont avec les noir les
Juifs sont avec les les musulmans les
blancs sont avec les Noirs tout ça se
mélange on est dans un dialogue et en
fait quand vous sortez de la maison et
que vous voyez que mais pas du tout en
fait vous vivez dans un monde qui
n'existe pas et au fond c'était une
déclaration d'amour que m'a fait mon
père en creux de dire va bosser h je
l'ai pris vraiment de manière j'ai dit
mais en fait pour il m'aime pas mon père
ne m'aime pas en fait mon père ne me
comprend pas il ne m'aime pas j'ai des
fachot en face de moi qui me mettent des
troit alors que je bosse 16 heur par
jour prof des profs et mon père me dit
va bosser et en fait je comprends
aujourd'hui mais m'a fallu du temps que
lorsque l'on bosse c'estàd qu'on est
victime de discrimination mais lorsque
l'on travaille à la fin le travail il
vous appartient c'estàd qu'il s'agit pas
de dire je suis noir je suis victimisé
je suis discriminé et cetera oui mais
quand on prend sa sa revanche pas sa
vengeance mais sa revanche en
travaillant en gardant en fait cette
cette force qui vous fait répliquer par
le travail et ben vous arrivez à vous en
sortir et c'est le message que j'essaie
de transmettre aux plus jeunes et
surtout qui je suis moi en Afrique on a
quelque chose par rapport aux aînés on
les respecte perdument bien sûr et je
trouve que les décoloniaux aujourd'hui
qui crachent sur la génération de mon
père qui ont vécu les indépendances qui
ont vécu qui se sont retrouvés ici dans
les années 60 qui ont réussi à être
professeur d'université dans les années
60 on peut pas se plaindre on doit
travailler j'ai une archive à vous
proposer Rachel Cann ah alors je vais
vous la mettre entre les mains mais
évidemment je vais euh la décrire pour
les gens qui nous écoutent il s'agit
d'un extrait du dossier de carrière CNRS
de Léopold Sédar sangor sangor ayant
sollicité une bourse pour achever sa
thèse commencée en 1938 interrompu par
la guerre l'occupation la captivité vous
avez sous les yeux l'avis du rapporteur
vendriè qui écrit ceci on est en
novembre 1944 avis très favorable
monsieur sangor me paraît qualifié pour
devenir un maître de la linguistique
africaine il mérite à tous égards d'être
aidé d'une large subvention qui lui
permetteent de se faire mettre en congé
afin de travailler librement à la
préparation de ces thèses et je crois
qu'il y a un petit lien entre sangor et
vous je crois qu'il a été il a commencé
sa carrière de prof de lettre classique
dans votre établissement dans votre
lycée à tour le lycée Descartes c'est
une figure importante pour vous très
importante très importante parce que
Sengor effectivement il y a il y a un
lien avec la Tourine agrégé de lettres
euh il était agrégé de lettres euh
latiniste
helléniste euh et puis puis l'autre lien
c'est que il est de l'ethnie de mon père
serè il se ressemble beaucoup et j'ai
une photo où ils sont tous les deux et
saingor lorsqu'il voyait mon père il lu
disait ah c'est le Gorgi et Gorgi en
fait c'est l'homme voici l'homme alors
qu'ils ont beaucoup d'écarts he donc mon
père devait être un jeune homme lorsque
il a rencontré singgor il a rencontré
donc saingor académicien premier
président du Sénégal après les
indépendances donc lui en fait il
conjugue enfin j'aimerais bien avoir le
regard des racialistes et des
décoloniaux sur la vie de saintgor euh
et puis saintgor c'est l'excellence il a
écrit des choses sur la réparation
notamment prière à mon frère aux yeux
aux yeux bleus prière à lui alors même
qu'il a vécu tout ça il a vécu la guerre
il restait pas dans l'amertume il était
là dans il a créé la francophonie il
était là dans le dialogue il a créé des
ponts des liens et il a rencontré mon
père lorsqu'il a eu le le festival des
ARS
au Sénégal où mon père était
bénévole et mon père a eu la chance de
dîner à la table de Joséphine Becker et
de saintgor qu'est-ce qui vous inspire
ce document parce que il dit tout le
travail et tout le mérite de saintgor et
lui accorde une large subvention ça dit
un lien très fort aussi entre la France
et l'Afrique même si je je sais ce que
vous dirait les des coloniaux le lien
entre la France et l'Afrique n'était pas
saint à l'époque de sangor il a permis
il était pas saint mais était très
lucide c'était quand même un fervant
enfin c'est pas un fervant c'était le
créateur avec ces air de ce qu'on
appelle la négritude donc il a créé un
un courant littéraire évidemment il y a
eu ce soutien et ça me fait penser aussi
au soutien qu'a eu mon père avec le
British conouncil c'estàd que mon père
était premier de sa classe et il a eu ce
soutien pour lui permettre de de faire
ses études ce sont des enfants qui sont
nés dans des endroits pas d'eau pas
d'électricité pas de livr mon père il
adorait les soirs de pleine lune parce
qu'il avait un livre et ça lui
permettait de le relire toute la nuit et
en fait c'est ça le truc c'est c'est
comment faire grandir nos humanités en
partant de rien et avec son propre récit
singor qui nous amène aussi à parler de
politique vous aussi d'une certaine
manière vous êtes dans l'univers
politique vous êtes conseillère
politique je crois que méiaapart vous a
appelé le visage du
macronisme comment vous prenez tout cela
et qu'est-ce que c'est que d'être
conseillère politique finalement votre
rôle c'estd oui c'est-à-dire que j'ai
surtout mon visage pourquoi m'assigné
encore une nouvelle étiquette ça leur
suffit PASF je suis juive je suis franç
je suis française en un je suis noire je
suis blanche je suis musulmane je suis
juive et là maintenant on me remet un
visage du
macronisme pourquoi signer toujours
pourquoi encore des nouvelles étiquettes
enfin j'ai mon propre visage et avec ce
visage là j'essaie de réfléchir essayie
de penser à ce qui pourrait euh redonner
de la force et de la puissance à notre
République voilà sans passer à l'action
sans se présenter un mandat par exemple
c'est quelque chose auquel vous pouvez
penser j'ai déjà mon mandat moi je crois
vraiment c'estàd qu'en fait je fais je
fais beaucoup enfin je je je je vais sur
tous les territoires j'écris des livres
enfin j'essaie de d'utiliser tous les
médias on a parlé de des réseaux sociaux
tout à l'heure mais il y a aussi des
évidemment les bouquins
évidemment les films aussi le terrain je
vais en détenenstion parler à des
fichiers S mais pas parler juste une
fois j'ai j'ai voilà j'ai organisé enfin
des des ateliers sur de très longues
périodes où j'allais voir les fichers s
toutes les semaines ou même sur les
détenus avec des longues peines en tout
cas j'essaie de m'imprégner du terrain
pour ensuite réfléchir et donner
quelques pistes quelques chemins à nos
représentant vous envoyez des effets
concrets parfois je dirais pas une
réforme mais peut-être un article un
décret quelque chose qui viendrait de ce
que vous avez apporté j'envoie des
choses oui oui j'en voie des des choses
et notamment sur ce qui m'anime le plus
c'est-à-dire la culture je trouve très
dommage de ne pas avoir une vision très
forte aujourd'hui sur la culture la
culture c'est pas que des budgets c'est
pas que des tableaux Excel la culture
c'est de savoir comment épauler au mieux
nos artistes parce que nous sommes dans
une guerre
culturelle j'ai aussi des photos pour
vous Rachel Cann ça fait partie des
rituels de cette émission la première
photo que j'ai eu envie de vous
présenter c'est celle de Kamala Haris
vice-présidente des États-Unis sous Joe
Biden de mère indienne de père jamaïcain
elle a été accusée de trahison raciale
parce que marié à un homme blanc est-ce
que vous craignez que ce genre de
reproche et de critique arrive en France
ah mais moi c'est les critiques que je
reçois euh depuis que j'ai écrit racé
tout allait bien
lorsque j'étais là pour pardon mais de
donner des subventions justement pour
soutenir certaines personnes qui se
disent racisé et que je me taisais tout
allait bien jusqu'au jour où ils ont
dépassé selon moi des limite à faire du
racialisme et où j'ai commencé à écrire
des des ouvrages et où j'ai été traité
de traître et de et de négresse
de maison à partir du moment où vous
êtes libre et c'est ce qui ressort aussi
de là de ce de du document de sainggor
afin de travailler librement à partir du
moment où vous êtes libre c'est
paradoxal à partir du moment où vous
êtes affranchi et vous n'êtes plus
assigné assigné vous n'êtes plus
l'esclave vous n'êtes plus le troupeau
donc en fait o où vous êtes
profondément euh indépendante donc là je
fais un clin d'œil aux décoloniaux h et
ben c'est là où on vous dit que vous
êtes traître et c'est dommage parce que
à chaqueis fois qu'on a des
personnalités qui sont censé être des
modèles
d'émancipation ils sont qualifiés de
traître et on les attaque j'ai une autre
photo pour vous alors c'est une photo
qui
représente un un un bout de tableau de
cette cérémonie d'ouverture du Mondial
de rugby 2023 en France jeens du jardin
la baguette le Marcel le beret tout y
était Adriana caramb comme représentante
d'une certaine manière de la française
type Libération a parlé de la France
Rance et vous moi je trouve que
Libération avec ce titre
incarne dans la pensée la sous frrance
Jean du jardin est l'un de nos plus
grands
artistes à chaque fois qu'on a des
grands artistes on n jamais fier en fait
d'avoir des grands artistes il crée il
a été reconnu de manière internationale
il a eu un Oscar h et on lui crache
dessus c'est ça la France France une
toute dernière photo il s'agit du
quartier des hallles qu'on appelait le
Ventre de Paris un quartier que vous
connaissez bien pour avoir été la
co-directrice de la place centre
culturel hip hop sous la canopé lesal
c'est aussi la France que vous aimer
cette France des carrefours de culture
oui alors c'est vraiment dommage que
lesal ne rayonne pas plus
[Musique]
c'est-à-dire ne soit en fait c'est ce
mélange en fait je veux je voudrais pas
que l'al devienne un getto h voilà euh
c'est vrai que c'est un quartier que je
connais
bien il faut que ça reste un quartier
véritablement ouvert avec toutes les
pratiques et toutes les esthétiques et
pas replié sur lui-même exactement une
dernière question en lien avec le lieu
dans lequel nous sommes nous sommes
entourés de quatre statues chacune
représentant une vertu il y a la sagesse
la prudence la justice et l'éloquence le
rituel de cette émission c'est de
demander à notre invité dans la quelle
de ses vertus il se retrouve le plus ça
peut être une autre si celle-ci ne vous
correspondent pas la justice elle est en
face de moi en plus c'est bien de
célébrer les statutes il faut les
protéger nos statuts aujourd'hui le
message est très clair merci Rachel
d'avoir été notre invité ici dans un
monde un regard merci d'avoir été et
d'avoir répondu si sincèrement
évidemment émission que vous pouvez
aussi écouter en podcast j'espère que
vous le savez maintenant merci à
beaucoup à vous de nous avoir suivi
merci beaucoup merci merci
[Musique]